the western is a classic film genre so
it's no surprise that over the decades
some have endured to not only be great
in its category but among the best
movies ever from old-timey classics to
violent spaghetti westerns these are the
only near-perfect westerns according to
metacritic
spaghetti westerns reached new heights
with the good the bad and the ugly
sergio leone's epic 1966 story of three
gunfighters on the trail of some
confederate gold leone had pioneered
italy's run of stylish stark yet
grandiose westerns with the great a
fistful of dollars which set up clint
eastwood as the man with no name alone
and unpredictable anti-hero who was good
with a gun and always on the move in the
good the bad and the ugly he's back and
not even nicknaming him blondie can hide
how dangerous he is
the tension runs high as blondie forms a
weary partnership with banded tuko to go
after the gold they might betray each
other or they might run afoul of the
cruel capable angel eyes who's also on
the trail the result is a movie as
hauntingly beautiful as it is violent it
serves up both a mythic american west
and one that's stripped of all the
old-fashioned lore of good guys and
their white hats it's a genre defining
film that absolutely deserves its 90 on
metacritic
released in 2007 no country for old men
has a 91 on metacritic and it definitely
deserves its place among the top ranked
westerns the coen brothers go especially
dark for this tale of stolen drug money
violent times and the forces of chance
and fate the movie pulled in an
incredible oscar hall taking home
statues for best pitcher best director
best supporting actor and best adapted
screenplay the story is a film noir plot
set in a western world luellen moss is
out hunting one day when he stumbles on
the grisly aftermath of a shootout and a
briefcase full of cash he takes it and
that decision changes everything enter
the terrifying off-kilter anton chagar a
hired killer who's supposed to retrieve
the money and who's so ruthless and
violent in pursuit of it that his own
employers regret bringing him in i don't
think that's how i'd describe him how
would you describe him
well i guess i'd say he doesn't have a
sense of humor trying to make sense of
it all is the weary ed tom bell a
sheriff who's seen just about all he can
stand but who will have to see this
horror all the same no country for old
men is bleak funny and deeply memorable
especially for its villain with his bowl
haircut air pressure bolt gun and
insistence on high stakes coin flips
chigurh instantly became an icon
if you miss the rider there's never been
a better time to check it out director
chloe zao's oscar win for nomad land
gives you a great excuse for revisiting
her backlist and you'll have the benefit
of hitting one of the metacritic's top
westerns with a meta score of 92. the
rider is the story of brady whose life
on the pro rodeo circuit is cut short
when an accident leaves him with a brain
injury that causes seizures he's not
supposed to ride again a lot of movies
would follow an inspirational sports
movie template and end with brady back
at the height of his powers but the
writer is more restrained and realistic
instead we follow brady's struggle to
adjust to falling back into a life of
limited options and even less glory
film critic godfrey cheshire notes that
the documentary like realism is one of
the film's strengths what you're seeing
from horse training to trauma to
friendship is often real zao handles all
of this delicately with both empathy and
respect it's a vision of the modern
american west that's rooted in real life
and real people and that makes it sing
clocking in on metacritic with a score
of 93 rio bravo isn't just one of the
best westerns it's one of the all-time
great team-up movies it was director
howard hawk's cinematic rebuttal to high
noon which he thought made its sheriff
too wishy-washy and ineffective rio
bravo has a laid-back unhurried pace it
has shootouts and action but it's also a
classic hangout movie where a lot of the
fun comes from watching the low-key
interaction between the likable
characters one of the contrasts with
high noon is that sense of friendliness
here when trouble strikes and there's
going to be a raid on the local jail
john wayne's sheriff john t chance
rounds up a team of motley allies they
might seem unqualified or all washed up
but he sees something in them and with
charming performances from dean martin
ricky nelson angie dickinson and walter
brennan we see something in them too fun
john ford's stagecoach with the 93 on
metacritic has a simple and irresistible
premise take one stagecoach fill it with
a cast of colorful characters and put it
in enough danger that all the characters
will have to rise to the occasion in
order to stay alive
the result is a terrific movie one
that's both exciting and emotionally
involving it also provided john wayne's
breakout role as the ringo kid the heart
of gold outlaw whose gentle courtship of
saloon girl dallas is one of the movie's
highlights and it cemented jon ford as a
western specialist as he'd go on to make
other classics making the film feel even
more important this one's not a classic
because of the role it played in movie
history it's just that enjoyable the
cave and mrs miller is robert altman's
version of the west and with a
metacritic score of 93 it's a very good
one muddy and mumbly and morally
ambiguous with its blend of brutality
and poetry and its sense of the
tumultuous life of a whole town it feels
like an ancestor of tv's deadwood the
film offers wonderful performances from
warren beatty and julie christie as the
two title characters they start out as
business partners in mccabe's brothel
and eventually drift into a kind of
romance but the love story isn't
necessarily a hopeful one and the boom
in business doesn't keep them out of
trouble none of this is destined to end
well that nearly dreamlike quality is
important because altman was reinventing
how movies worked while parts of his
unconventional approach like the way the
dialogue is deliberately hard to make
out might frustrate viewers the
complexity here is rewarding mccabe and
mrs miller will linger in your mind long
after the credits have rolled
with a meta score of 94 we have 1950s
the gunfighter which depicts an age-old
problem when you're the best you're also
the one everyone wants to beat sooner or
later there's nowhere to go but down
gregory peck plays jimmy ringo famous as
the best gun fighter in the west he's so
famous in fact that he always attracts
trouble there are too many men looking
to kill him and take up his mantle he's
constantly having to fight for his life
and when his challengers are dead their
families sometimes show up seeking
revenge all he wants at this point is to
reconnect with his estranged wife and
finally meet his son but his reputation
threatens to make it impossible the
tension and tragedy of the movie worked
together to give it an almost hypnotic
pull its look at the hollowness of
celebrity and the sorrow of a life spent
on killing once put the movie ahead of
its time now that approach makes the
movie immortal
the searchers may not sit quite at the
top of metacritic's list but it still
has a solid claim to being the best
western ever made
in 2008 the american film institute
honored it with that distinction and
sight and sound went even further by
declaring it the seventh best film of
all time period it's easy to see why the
movie attracts so many admirers the
compelling story that follows john
wayne's ethan edwards going after his
kidnapped niece takes a heroic premise
and twists it the result exposes all the
brutality and racism that can lie
beneath the legends of the old west
because the unsettling truth is that
ethan isn't trying to save debbie he
only wants to kill her so she won't have
to live with having been quote despoiled
by her comanche abductors that
deep-seated anger and prejudice make for
one of wayne's most complex performances
known you stay out of this i love you i
don't want you with me
i'll need you for what i gotta do
director john ford portrays all this
viscerally and accompanies it with some
extraordinary landscapes giving the
searchers a desolate but beautiful sense
of place the combination makes for an
incredibly influential movie harsh
striking and powerful this isn't just a
movie it's a cultural landmark
even if you haven't seen the man who
shot liberty valance you might know its
most famous quote
this is the west sir
when the legend becomes fact
print the legend the quote fits the
movie which is a classic with a 94 on
metacritic the man who shot liberty
valance is all about how tall tales and
legends helped shape the old west it
zooms in on one story in particular the
intersection of the fates of future
senator ransom stoddard practical
rancher tom donovan and wicked outlaw
liberty valance valance terrorizes the
town of shinbone while stoddard wants to
bring it closer to civilization and
order tom stands somewhere in between
the two his intentions are good but he
lives by a violent code that stoddard
can't approve of something has to give
and when it does it will make history
but will the history be the truth john
ford directed a number of celebrated
westerns but the man who shot liberty
valance as roger ebert points out is
quote the most pensive and thoughtful if
you want to see how lawless territories
became lawful and what was won and lost
in the process this is the film for you
the wild bunch earned its meta score of
97 by drastically shaking up the western
template this 1969 film pumped the genre
full of controversial and unprecedented
levels of cynicism and violence giving
us a vietnam war era look at all the
supposed cowboy heroes of times gone by
the men in the wild bunch mostly live
sordid lives their vicious outlaws with
very little honor they don't hesitate to
kill and they're quick to use human
shields when they think it will help
their whole world is one of cruelty and
violence but just before this
unrelenting parade of misery and
cutthroat behavior becomes too much
director sam peckinpah tosses in an
actual moral dilemma one member of the
gang is kidnapped and tortured can the
others bring themselves to risk their
lives for him while the movie certainly
attracted plenty of criticism for its
viciousness time has definitely been on
its side in a retrospective review
rolling stone said the hard action
bracing wit and mournful grace of
peckenpaw's cowboy classic shames every
new movie around it's a towering
achievement that grows more riveting and
resonant with the years
the top rated western on metacritic with
a score of 98 the treasure of the sierra
madre is famous for its grim tragic
portrayals of greed in action humphrey
bogart plays fred c dobbs a down on his
luck man whose health and sanity unravel
over the course of the film that's what
can happen when you go prospecting even
when you find gold you tend to lose
everything else
watches
wayne got no badges
we don't need no badges
i don't have to show you any stinking
brushes dobbs and his friends go out
into the sierra madre mountains to dig
for gold the surroundings are
inhospitable the work is exhausting and
the men are increasingly paranoid the
tension is almost unbearable and bogart
vividly evokes dobb's fraying mental
state it all leads up to a tragic ironic
twist that even the twilight zone would
envy the film still stands as one of the
few to have a perfect rotten tomato
score and to sum it all up slant says
this deservingly canonized behemoth is
one of the relatively few films that
transcends the medium to become a
mandatory viewing experience for anyone
that identifies themselves as a human
being period
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite film classics are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you